welcome back to las vegas now sticking
to your financial goals for the new year
can be done with the help of the
financial literacy program from silver
state schools credit union who are the
sponsors of this segment mercedes caught
up with the president for more
i am a member of silver state schools
credit union i tell everyone i know and
one of the reasons why i love being a
member and i think everyone should be a
member is because of the financial
literacy tools that you provide to your
members and i love it as a mom that my
kids can learn how to be financially
illiterate how does the credit union
help members who are trying to learn
more about managing their finances here
at silver state schools priority union
we offer free financial literacy tools
that are that really anyone can use and
people using our financial literacy
program can learn about a wide variety
of topics that set you on a path to
financial success and one of my
favorites is our money moves program
it's a free online financial education
center that offers interactive courses
to help you learn about things from
managing your own finances to setting up
a budget to financing a car or even
owning a home
and another great resource uh is our
partnership with a balance program
that's been one of my favorites for a
long long time i've actually brought it
before credit unions believe it or not
and it actually offers members free
financial guidance services like live
webinars and financial counseling um you
could they'll set up a budget for you
and do all sorts of things and um both
of those programs are actually uh
they're available on our website uh yeah
and that's at silverstatebu.com
and they're believe it or not they're
available free of charge if you're a
member of silver state schools credit
union i have learned so much using the
tools that you've made available to us
members another thing is just it's like
you mentioned achieving those long-term
financial goals how does silver state
schools credit union help with that um
really all you need to do is go into any
of our 10 francis
in the southern nevada valley here
or call our call center and set up an
appointment with any of our
representatives uh and and we've got
representatives uh through uh lpl
financial and we'll uh we'll set up a
meeting with any one of those
representatives and they can
they can help you on any of those
long-term goals at any time the
automobile market is crazy right now
cars are very expensive and a lot of
people are
kind of reconsidering whether they want
to buy a new car or they just want to
refinance their current auto loan and
silver state schools credit union can
help with that service state school's
credit union has a thing called a abc or
a better car
auto loan that provides an opportunity
to save up to two percent off your
current auto loan when you refinance
your current auto loan uh with an auto
loan with uh silver state school's
credit union it's a great offer that
allows you to lower your current
interest rate and reduce your
monthly auto loan
payment and all you got to do to learn
more about that that program is to visit
silverstatecu.com
abc
loan
in touch with silver state schools
credit union by calling 702-733-8820
or visit silverstatecu.com
las vegas now we'll be right back